hello and welcome to our video on
Mastery goals let's review a few tips to
ensure you are making the most out of
your learning experience while working
on Khan Academy first let's make sure
you're logged into your Khan Academy
account by checking for your name in the
upper right hand corner
now on the left side you should see your
classes where your teacher has given you
a Mastery goal or an assignment to work
on
click on the tab that says Mastery goals
to view the goals your teachers have set
for you
now that you're viewing and focused on
your learning goals let's discuss the
top five strategies for mastering goals
on Khan Academy
number one your Mastery goals are
important goals set by your teacher
on your learner homepage you can track
your progress toward the Mastery goal
along with the due date your teacher has
assigned
simply click on the master goal to
access the course homepage here you'll
find the course units and your progress
towards mastering each unit
keep an eye on the purple bar that fills
from left to right as you progress
through each unit
regularly check your unit progress to
ensure you're on track to achieve your
goal
click into a unit to see your Mastery
level for each skill on the left hand
side
aim to earn a crown for every skill and
move your Mastery level to mastered next
Embrace time and practice
Mastery requires time and practice as
you practice skills and answer questions
your Mastery level for each skill will
rise with correct answers and decline
with incorrect ones
if you wish to accelerate your progress
consider trying a Mastery challenge
these challenges allow you to reinforce
the skills you've already practiced
through through six Focus questions
remember Mastery is a meaningful
achievement and the effort you put in to
reach it demonstrates true learning
don't be afraid to retry exercises until
you achieve a score you're satisfied
with
Embrace struggles and mistakes as they
contribute to your brain's growth
make sure to follow the guiding blue
buttons throughout the platform your
course contains a number of skills that
you can practice at your own pace
to stay on track look for the blue
buttons through the course
these buttons will always guide you to
the next skill that you should work on
don't forget to utilize hints when
you're stuck it's completely normal to
feel stuck while learning new skills the
key is to not give up when you encounter
difficulties take advantage of the hint
feature hints provide step-by-step
instructions for the specific question
you're working on and you can jot them
down for future reference
Additionally you can watch instructional
videos or read articles on the skill to
gain further insights
once you've done this attempt the
exercise again and if you're still stuck
don't hesitate to seek support from your
classmates teachers or family members
lastly Embrace Mastery learning always
remember your potential to succeed knows
no bounds keep trying Embrace making
mistakes and never hesitate to seek help
when needed the beauty of learning on
Khan Academy lies in the endless
possibilities for growth and knowledge
by employing these strategies you'll be
well equipped to work towards your
Mastery goals effectively on Khan
Academy
[Music]
thank you
foreign